[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question what are our top 10 most
influential TV shows yeah so over the
course of our lives we've watched our
fair share of television and in it's
interesting as I started thinking about
this at certain pockets of my life I was
watching a lot more television and and
other times less and so I think that my
list which I have not shared with you
and you have not shared your top 10 list
with me that's what we're about to do
oh that and share it with you listener
it it it was really a truck trucking
back down memory lane you know and it uh
I was I was pleasantly surprised by the
things that came up when I started
thinking about the television shows that
not only influenced me in terms of like
my creative brain but also in terms of
my life just just personal impact so
this is not necessarily our favorite
television shows but it kind of kind of
is like have a lot of honorable mentions
I would say most significant most thing
I would be most significant in our lives
yeah it's not as clear and easy to say
Franklin Winchell but this is not what
we believe to be our top 10 best
television shows of all time no not even
close these are ones that we have
personal connections to in one form or
another which we can flesh out as we go
through these things yeah and I think so
while we did not share the list with one
another the one thing that we did do
just so you can understand the the
exercise is that we did tell each other
that we would be going back through our
lives so yeah it was kind of going back
to like the first television shows you
could remember being significant and I I
kind of just I went through my entire
life okay
and I didn't do it that way but that
that's what I'm saying is is that just
to give you an idea where they come from
you know some are gonna be yeah when we
were a kid some are more
more recent not too many now all at mine
are current no just kidding
but the reason why I thought to have
this conversation was because something
happened over the break that I chose not
to share with you a couple of weeks back
when I was giving my update on the
holiday break in my family time and when
I went to Sedona but so the thing I
didn't tell you something very special
happened that our family bonded over
something and it was the reality
competition show known as survivor have
you heard of this show this is a little
weird isn't it but it turns out survivor
became a very special part of my
family's holiday Breaking and a-any very
unintuitive bonding experience you know
whatever it takes me exactly what
whatever it takes
what everybody together exactly it a
magical thing happened but a little
backstory when we were on tour in
Australia we went back to our rooms we
were in Sydney we were like in that
high-rise apartment yeah and I live in
towards the end of that the Sydney part
of the trip there was just one night
we're like let's just order in you kind
of get to a point in your trip where
you're like I just don't think we can
mobilise everybody to go out to eat
again and I feel a little over it so we
just stayed in the room and ordered
pizza and I put on the television I was
like hey let's watch some Australian
television because you have been talking
about how nice everybody was you were
learning a lot about the culture it was
very very nice like the Neil's need to
do that too so we turn it on and it was
um the Australian version of Survivor
just happened to be on I'm like kids
this is look at this as survivor and
they're like what and I was like well
it's a it's a it's basically a game show
well not it's a it's a reality
competition show basically I was having
trouble it's like you know American Idol
and like The Voice or reality
competition shows where people sing but
it turns out that these these other ones
where they take a group of people and
they just strand them out on
Island or something they had never heard
they had never heard of survivor I would
have thought that like survivor was like
in memes or something in some way I have
some weight kids find out about I just
don't think it's cool enough for that I
kind of told you that survivor was still
going on but lo and behold here it was
and this is the Australian version of
Survivor but it happened to be an
episode where they were bringing in
I think heroes and villains from
previous survivals they're already there
at Australia as well well one of the
guys was from America a famous guy who I
won't mention because I can't remember
his name but he's from another our
Americans as cool to Australians as
Australians are to America could you
sense that in the way that they like set
him up it was one of the first episodes
of the season and they voted the guy off
so I'll put it ok apparently not so
apparently you have a correct
understanding of America but I was like
I was like oh you don't know about
Survivor so we just started watching it
and we just watched the one episode out
of context in everybody I just kind of
made a mental note everybody seemed to
be into it yeah they're asking questions
about how Survivor worked as a game and
stuff like that so I just made a mental
note got back to the States
I and Jett Jeff Probst was not involved
directly no he was not hosting right
he's not directly involved I get back
here we're like we're filming a couple
of weeks ago and I think Kevin brought
up something about surviving I was like
huh will you just talk about survivor he
was like yeah John and I are like big
survivor fans if you see the two of us
or maybe somebody else chimed in if you
see the two of them together
I can guarantee you they're talking
about survivor and I was like I would
have laughed at you just two weeks ago
well before my Australian trip but the
funny thing that happened and I told him
this story and they were like I was like
I think my I think we should start
watching survivor like I think my family
will be into it he was like oh well you
need you definitely should it's amazing
and you know they're like giddy and both
into it and I'm like you guys are dorks
but okay whatever yeah definitely and
they said you should watch the
Millennials vs. Gen X season which was
like three seasons ago so pretty recent
it's still going it is really good
there's like there's like 400 seasons of
this thing
no literally I think there's like 36
seasons it is still going I didn't even
know it twice a year for almost 20 years
I guess so the week leading up to our
our trip like the kids are getting out
of school we're like you know school
works dying down like I start putting on
the survivor and everybody gets into it
like every single member of the family
unlike I mean it's so hard to pick out a
movie or a television show that
everybody can get into but Lando loved
it because it was like adventurous and
outdoors and oh that one's in Fiji where
we went right you know sounds like we've
been to Fiji we've experienced kind of
where we were like at a resort not at a
resort not exactly the same thing like
Lincoln it he loves strategy games like
he loves strategy so he's into that
Lilly really enjoyed the humor of kind
of laughing at these people basically
becoming characters and Christy really
enjoyed all of it I don't know exactly
what Christy loved but I'd like she
likes the guys with the merits off guys
with the shirts off there was a model a
male model where she does and survivor
body they can I liked the production
like the thing that I would pause
survivor and I would say do you guys do
you see how brilliant the production is
Rhett Rhett they have it down I know
this sounds ludicrous but they have it
no no they have it down to a sign
what's ludicrous is pausing and
explaining it to your family
appreciating it no I am totally on the
same hey I was just overflowing with joy
it's a production wonder but we've
talked about this in fact we've talked
about this very specific that dad think
it can't be that I do the same thing you
cannot be the dad who makes your family
stop and acknowledge how awesome
something is because you think it's
awesome
you have to just give it to them and let
them experience it on their own terms
and and they eat no more pausing they
each had their thing but I was trying to
get him to appreciate what I appreciate
which was after all of these seasons
they've got I mean the people the
contestants some of them are they're
obsessed with the game players survivor
so they're really good at it and they
invent new ways to play it
like new strategies come out but the way
that they present it in terms of the the
editing and they bring story out and you
have these these like character arcs is
masterful I mean it really is amazing to
me and so it's I might have to alter my
listen to put survivor on there like it
is a know yourself so oh you're saying
survivor is not after all this survivor
is not on your list it should be now
because I mean it just seems so fresh I
don't know if it's gonna stand the test
of time because when we every night at
Sedona we would like to hiking and
everything I talked about but then we
would also be talking about survivor
like we have something that everybody
could talk about together during the day
and then at night we'd be like hey let's
all get on our PJs and let's make some
popcorn and let's sit down and have our
survivor session like everybody was into
it and like while we were hiking
Christians are like wow this is this is
this is a rare gem of a moment thank you
Jeff Probst and so are you
like how much do you watch in a sitting
we would watch two or three episodes Wow
in a sitting and so we finished it the
night before we were leaving Sedona and
they were like let's watch another one
so like we're out we're out to dinner
and like I'm googling what's the what
are the best seasons of Survivor there's
like this like very involved reddit
thread a survivor reddit thread where
people talk about which one of the best
seasons and which ones to watch and this
one's the best but you have to watch
this one before because it spoils
something about the strategy so and so I
figured it I figured all that out more
we're gonna watch China and so we come
back and start watching it and I'm like
what are you watching it all I'm worth
platform a laptop know what platform
like a coffee table
now I'm messing with you hulu hulu has
survivor all of them okay and i
immediately notice people are gushing
about how great the season is i'd never
watched it the only season i had watched
was chrissie and i like in our second
year of marriage we watched season
three survivor outback Australia and
there was a goat farmer he was very
funny
I only season and I think that it was it
was a phenomenon yeah that time like
Jesse and I watched multiple seasons it
was appointment television yes season
two season two was like the number one
show on till I remember when it came out
just I didn't watch that I'm just
thinking it was like this is so this is
changing everything this is changing
everything yeah and we can't we had to
watch it and then I don't know what
reality competition shows really became
mainstream Elauf then on the back end of
that Christian are watching things like
the mole hosted by Anderson Cooper yep
that was weird like Amazing Race but
anyway we started watching the China
when everybody's excited it was the
night after watching you know the finale
and having this big moment this sense of
closure first thing I noticed who was in
for three not widescreen this episode
that read it said was one of the best
ones was 4:3 and is this much earlier so
the things that they no longer do on
Survivor they did in that season which
was like I can't hear it
haha did you you go finish it well I'll
skip to the chase and say that like we
didn't even finish that episode but I
don't think you can call yourself a real
survivor freak Oh what do they call it I
didn't do that the reddit thread did you
subscribe to the reddit thread no but I
have my hope so but I realized you know
it they were explaining more that we
already knew like why are these people
these people you know like Jeff was
doing these voiceovers like everyone
came in their own clothes not knowing
that we're about to take away their
luggage they don't even do that crap
anymore they're like let's get to the
game people are coming in they're like
the Gen Xers are coming in on this boat
and the Millennials are coming and
they're like cutting the interview
footage about how the cultures are
different and it's masterful but they've
gotten over all the crap of like what
you know you just expect the business
guy is gonna be in a business suit and
you're not gonna ask any questions
it's part of the game it literally has
become much more of a game show than
something that
they had to like motivate in reality all
the things that were happening if that
makes sense it moved it the setup took
longer and you get attached to these
characters and then they're gone and you
got to start from scratch all over so
what season you drawn the line at what
what we deceptive all we haven't come
back to it because I just feel like
we'll never recapture the magic of you
know them you let you let four three
ruin your whole family's bonding I did
the other thing it was just I think the
cadence of Survivor you got to go away
from it for a little bit oh so we're
like let's just you can hail it rocks
are lots of good things about the good
place Christy says let's watch the good
place a little different different vibe
so now we as a family or hooked on the
good place so I actually think that
television what we've we're now
discovering our kids are of an age that
they're they're enjoying things that I
actually enjoy and I'll get to one on my
list which will lead to more
conversation about this but I mean yeah
Lando is younger but because I mean
Lily's almost 16
Lincoln's almost 14 they're developing a
sense of humor that is we can watch the
same stuff and enjoy it is know like two
years ago we were we would watch the
flash when it came out because they were
really into that you know it's difficult
and yeah Lily's in a Teen Wolf and to
stick around was Doctor Who now it's
like Teen Wolf and some other shows like
that that I do really don't care for I
can take a season of but there to take a
season to the flesh you know what I'm
saying oh I I enjoyed the flash I
enjoyed watching it with them but I
didn't enjoy it for myself right yeah
yeah but now we're getting into comedies
that we can we can watch like the good
place we're all watching it we're having
a blast my wife and children watch that
what started that without me so now I
just kind of get in where I fit in
that's not quite the same you yeah you
got to start at the beginning you gotta
watch it straight through what I want to
do now can't could be a guy in the Attic
really watching TV you can't watch you
can't watch the good place piecemeal you
gotta watch it as a linear chronological
experience yeah
but I'm you know I'm really myself with
television in a way like I haven't
watched sitcoms for years again well
I'll get into some of this in my list
but I'm just I'm figuring out that like
the television and this may sound sad is
actually it's a great tool to bring us
together as a family and I and I and I
was missing it hmm but because of
Survivor and I think we will go back to
survivor but I see it's gonna you know
let's go through a few off show but so
then we can come back it happened over
the holidays that we will move on in a
second but when are you finding that
this time is this are you how you see
you scheduling it well weekend's when is
this happening like what how are you
getting everybody together a white
television at the same time before I
mean after dinner before bedtime you
know it's like before so like that eight
to nine o'clock is this happening once a
week is this how I haven't scheduled it
like I mean they don't happen is it
happen they don't have a lot of homework
yet cuz yeah that's the thing is that
just gearing up but it's pray it'll
probably fizzle and it might just be a
weekend thing where it's like hey
instead of watching a movie let's bend
watch four episodes or whatever show
that we can all agree on because a movie
a movie is is one and done it's it's
basically impossible for us all to agree
on a movie mm-hmm that's probably not
true but I don't have a good list of
like comedies good movie experiences but
the television experience the way that
it it continues to grow there's there's
episodes so you can like have
conversations and talk about it at
dinner and then come back to it as
opposed to a movie talking about
survivor at dinner huh invite me over
next time okay we are gonna talk about
these top 10 most influential television
shows but first I'm going to talk about
the top four most influential wristbands
that I'm wearing now yeah you've been
seeing me even looking at my wrist I
know those of you watching and you know
you're only talking to people watching
but what is what is well some people
turn the video on and just listen I
heard about that is that right you've
heard about that yeah heard about it
didn't see it I'm not making a fashion
statement
unless you think I should be I just
wanted to show you the four available
colors of the mythical wristband it's a
it is a polymer some kind smells like
rubber and gives you some they'll fit
around where would they get it most
every wrist mythical dot store one size
fits all one size fits most there's
other stuff too
there's pins there's I doubt it sockets
I doubt it would fit like Andre the
Giant can you imagine how big his wrist
was right now well I probably fit it now
he's probably just a shriveled bone
that's why did I say that I mean that's
I don't think the bones shrivel yeah
mythical does store okay so let's get
into these lists so what we do you have
any honorable mentions you want to start
with number 10 we're gonna go back and
forth I yes I had honorable mentions but
I have a feeling that some of some of
the ones that made our list might be in
each other's honorable mentions and
let's just if that happens it happens
but I don't want to mention up a good
point let's make them honorable let's
not mention them all right give me let's
start with your number 10 brother number
10 the a-team oh crap one of the reasons
that I was thinking about the a-team is
the way that my phone works when I plug
my phone into my car it automatically
starts playing the first song often I
don't know how when it decides to do
this often begins playing the first song
in my entire library which by
alphabetical order is the 18 and so I
and I think I've talked about this on
the show before because you've gotten
into my car and we're like having a
serious conversation coming back from a
meeting and all of a sudden in 1972 a
crack commando unit was sent to you know
say yeah cuz they now known as soldiers
of fortune if you can find them and you
know you whatever I can't remember it
I've heard it so many times and I
haven't memorized it but I was actually
in the car with Shepherd the other day
ne and started playing he was like what
is that he was very interested
oh yes that's again to tell him about
the a-team which again you know this was
a team of former military guys put
together they had a van driven by mister
teehee played ba Baracus and they would
just get into stuff nobody ever actually
got hurt because it was a network
television show but the reason that it
was so there were guns involved but no
one got shot the reason that it made my
list is because not as much as another
one that's higher up on my list oh yeah
but it is a show that defined the way
that I interacted with television as a
child meaning there was a specific you
probably remember specific nights and
times because that's how your brain
works I don't remember but I do remember
that there was a specific night in a
specific time where we had to be at the
television between the years of 1983 to
1987 to watch the a-team and my brother
and I most of the time would watch it
together in that span of our lives
I remember watching 18 more as reruns
and I actually don't think I was hooked
on it in real time I don't know what
happened but I did love it like when I
watched it but I remember watching it
during the day so it must have been
later uh you know is also I found it to
be this perfect at the time I'm sure it
doesn't hold up well but at the time it
was this perfect mix of comedy in action
and also just like you actually cared
about what was happening because just
the way that these guys interacted with
each other it was like there's a lot of
laugh-out-loud moments and just like the
way Hannibal had a cigar and said I love
it when a plan comes together
you know that and whenever they'd have
to fly somewhere they'd have to knock
mr. t out because he was afraid of
flying they'd have to knock him out yeah
and Murdock you know he was mentally ill
I mean I don't think you could do that
today I don't know I I didn't watch the
movie did you watch the movie no um I
don't ruin things Bradley Cooper played
face that makes sense in that movie and
I I mean I might watch anything Bradley
Cooper's in now so hmm I might go back
and watch the 18 movie yeah so that
that's my that's my number 10 my number
10 is mr. Rogers neighborhood so I I I
didn't go
logic for all of this but it just ended
up at number 10 this man who was so
schedule oriented you know in routine
his routine was impeccable
he always changed his shoes and he
always changed his sweater and he always
spoke directly to me you know I think
that's something that III just I think
that's the key to good mythical morning
is how we speak directly to one viewer
and I I'm gonna credit mr. Rogers for
that because I watched Sesame Street
religiously and then mr. Rogers
neighborhood would come on after it at
my babysitter his house when I was like
four or five early as I can remember
right but that was a that was a
meaningful connection like I had a
relationship with mr. Rogers what in I
watched the documentary what year did he
did did that stop did you it kept I mean
it kept going for a long time but I did
I did outgrow it yeah I I was I was a
fan like most kids but it would I didn't
pop into my head when I thought about
most influential I could I felt like I
couldn't miss it I felt like he would
know if I didn't watch the show like I I
felt as if I had a relationship with the
guy I don't I think there was something
about feeling like I was being taught
mm-hmm the parts I liked and remembered
about mr. Rogers neighborhood was when
he would go into what was the name of
the land whatever land and the puppets
even though the ten land even though he
was in those moments still teaching me I
don't know maybe I just is my issue with
authority like when it was just a man
sitting there just saying things and
trying to teach me license I would be
like boring old man sweater and then I
would be the oh the puppets no those are
cool that's just how I interacted with
Joe I I liked him a lot better than the
puppets hmm you scared of the puppets a
little bit weren't you a lot of kids
were I just didn't like puppets man cuz
you get all the voices I freaky I could
feel the hand there was a hand in there
that's wrong that's wrong maybe there
was a father figure thing happening and
Oh mr. Rogers was your stand-in father
yeah let's say that
okay but I mean his I got a kick out of
his son being interviewed for the for
the document a great documentary one of
the best that last year I recommend you
watch it if you have any connection of
Mister Rogers what's your number nine
The Fresh Prince of bel-air uh-huh
of course you know that many memes have
been created about this if you didn't
happen to see it when it happened
between 1990 1996 but for me this was
this is like the first obviously I
watched like growing pains and family
ties and all those the sitcoms coming up
but this was the first one I remember
watching the first episode yeah and just
think this is different men well it was
for it was it was the first one I think
to complete that thought that was made
for us
like somebody made a show amongst all
these other shows that we like family
ties is for the family perfect strangers
is you know I like strangers almost made
my list I well I would almost why I
would watch Frasier you know these shows
that like Hannah Frasier again there's
only so many shows so many channels and
nothing's on demand so you kind of had
to watch a stuff that was for adults and
he didn't where you fit in I do remember
that sense I don't know how we knew that
it was coming on I don't know how the
marketing got to us but I remember
watching that first expecting the first
episode you know having been such an
obsessive fan of yeah already fans of
the music and it's whoa this is the
first show that's made for us like I'm
trying I'm explaining to my mom this is
the this is the guy from parents just
don't understand right nightmare on mice
cuz there was the whole like Cosby Show
then the different world and he kind of
felt like a different world was a little
bit more because it was college it was a
little bit it was reaching a little bit
more into yeah our age group and I
watched it and liked it but this was all
of a sudden it was the age that we were
that you know in 1990 we were like 30 I
was like 13 mm-hm and so when it started
I was just about to begin
this whole high school experience and so
it was the perfect time and I just
thought everything about it was perfect
it was incredibly in and let me tell you
right now yeah it does hold up because
my kid it really does yeah my kids got
into watching The Fresh Prince of
bel-air a couple years ago when it was
my two on whatever platform it was on
its you can still get it but they ended
up watching every single episode in a in
like a few months like every time I got
home they will be watching another
episode of The Fresh Prince and then
telling me about what they were getting
into and I would sit down and watch some
of it and I was it's obviously it's
ridiculous in a lot of ways but yet for
me it changed the way I thought about
half-hour sitcom like studio based
sitcoms yeah and exactly what she said
it felt like it was for me and Will
Smith before he started his YouTube
channel I think it's on another YouTube
channel it might have been right when he
started nope I take it back when he
started his YouTube channel he told a
story and you if you if you're into the
fresh prints you got to look this up the
story of The Fresh Prince being made I
kinda don't want to spoil it but my mind
was blown by the fact that as big as a
celebrity he was like I don't know if he
won a Grammy Grammy nominated like he
was broke and he tells this story of
he's over at Quincy Jones house at a
party and like Quincy Jones has it has
the script or it's talking to a guy who
has a script I can't remember the story
exactly but basically puts him on the
spot to audition at the party and forces
him to do it even though he didn't want
he said I'm not ready I can't do this
right now and it was like this
make-or-break moment for Will Smith even
though from my perspective he was like
one of the biggest stars in the world
because he was this amazing amazingly
hilarious rapper yeah he was like the
Mister Rogers of rapping for me like I
felt like I had a relationship with him
and but he was broke he blown all those
money put all the money and he was
desperate and out of that desperation
came them rewriting this script that was
written for somebody else
for him and became The Fresh Prince of
bel-air he tells the story great what
sweetie doubt that is my number five oh
wow it's higher on my list man it was
just such a special time that was back
when and then is that next album was
gonna come out which ended up being a
flop but we were like waiting for it and
we didn't know when we didn't have
information there's no internet so I
remember what are you talking about this
on the news I remember going to do
eventually for if you didn't have cable
but I didn't have cable at my house so
there's no MTV every weekend I'd go to
get my mom to say we had a record bar
and I would just hope it would be there
and then I finally asked him and they
turns out the people there they knew
when albums are coming out I said oh
three more weeks it's coming out I
couldn't wait but to answer your
question about how we found out about
television shows it was commercials it
was you be watching a show and there
would be a commercial and you would
learn oh there's a new show that's got
the fresh prince in it and then you
would be like when is that coming on and
they would tell you when you would watch
it that was the only way you found out
about things yeah because it wasn't like
there was billboards and you could set
your VCR to tape it but I never did that
I just you'd miss him or you get him on
the rerun yeah we never ever did that my
number nine is I think you've alluded to
it later in your list the Dukes of
Hazzard hmm yes when you so number four
for me
Wow number four for you yeah Dukes of
Hazzard ran from 1979 in 1985 and I
don't know at what point Bo and Luke
were replaced by their cousins pretty I
mean in my mind is pretty late I did not
watch that no I tried that was a huge
betrayal of what I was interested in
yeah they weren't I thought they were
the same guys I thought they did what
they deal with years later with the
fresh Prince's aunt like the actress
changed yeah
after like next season comes back it's
like she's different Biff Biff but
anyway I mean it was just southern you
got this General Lee car which he can't
do that no no like I don't even I don't
even I'm not even gonna say that's a
good thing but I will say that half of
the fan mail that was sent to the show
was it was addressed to the General Lee
fun fact seriously yes I mean that that
racist car was was a character on the
show I had the car wasn't like KITT from
Knight Rider which didn't it didn't have
a personnel it had a confederate flag on
the top of the car right and I had that
car just to give you this just the way
we grew up I had that car in that model
car in my house on my shelf and I had a
bunch of dukes of hazzard like toys and
I have a Dukes of Hazzard Cup that I
think I still have in my house we didn't
we didn't call it Dukes of Hazzard like
you said the first time he's Dukes of
Hazzard Dukes Hazzard like I didn't even
know what that Hazzard was a county
really like I didn't like I didn't to me
Dukes of Hazzard was just one word yeah
we that meant every Thursday night I go
to my nanny's house and we're gonna
watch the Dukes of Hazzard
and then when that's over I have to sit
there while they watched Dallas mm-hmm
which came on right after not quite the
same that was not I was not into that
well all there was kissing on that the
reason that is so high in my list is
because like the a-team it's one of the
first shows that I could remember being
appointment television for my family but
the Dukes of Hazzard was the thing that
I thought about as early as I can
remember television and Cole and I my
brother and I would sometimes we would
dress up like Bo and Luke because he had
darker hair and I had my hair was pretty
blond at the time and we would dress up
like that
sometimes to watch the show and they
were cosplaying and then so the show was
on you just said through 79 to 85 so
yeah
when I moved to California now you may
if you watch the show you kind of see
the car running around you're like
that's not Georgia that doesn't look
like Georgia that looks like California
and of course I didn't know what
California looked like we moved to
California in 1984 and my dad says I'm
gonna take you to where they filmed the
Dukes of Hazzard and so I took us out to
I don't remember where it was but it was
the place that they would shoot all the
car scenes of the generally flying over
and the river and doing all the stunts
and stuff yeah it was like and it was
demolition derby and it was just that
would be a scene in every episode that
would be like the car the car doing some
well but the car would do a jump and
then it would pause and then Waylon
Jennings would say now these boys didn't
know what it was about to have it and
then it would come back and unpause the
car and then the car would land I mean
everything about that show at the time
in my life in the way that I was taking
in entertainment it just it it checked
all the boxes it wasn't I mean except
for the filming location it was so
distinctly southern like I felt like it
was a documentary like when I turn off
the television I got back in the car I
was driving around in Hazzard County
well I don't know how well you remember
it because you've heard this like Boss
Hogg did you know anybody who wore a
tall white suit with a top hat almost
I'm telling you in my world it wasn't
quite that great quite quiet extreme it
was it you know like with my relatives
in my world okay like it was I felt like
it was just a reflection of reality and
it was except for the way the cars
behaved when they you know hit obstacles
they would somehow I'll just be you know
it Jackie laid it into the air well okay
that's or projected into the air is what
maybe I should have said yeah they
probably use that word on the Dukes of
Hazzard I had a I had a play set where
you'd rev up the car and you'd let it go
on
thing in it and it would go through a
barn and it had a ramp inside of the
barn and when it came out the other side
of the barn it would like turn on its
side and then do a do a barrel roll and
land and I had that set at my nanny's
house yeah so yeah we'd watch that
together I mean it was just it was
magical man well we should move on we
got a lot to go what's your number nine
what well your number number eight
Animaniacs Wow we really do have a lot
of similar I thought our list is gonna
be totally different honestly I don't
know why so what number is Animaniacs
for you Animaniacs is number six for me
okay
so we're we're around the same way so I
think the Brad the guy who has it ranked
higher should start talking about it so
that was from 1993 to 1998 I remember
watching it after school yep
I I don't know that I could have
articulated it I I guess I would have to
it was the humor I mean it was so splat
salutely the specific jokes I mean like
pinkie in the brain I'm gonna consider
they it had its own spin-off show later
which I I've never actually watched but
that was gold and then the way that the
Animaniacs would they would say that I
think there was an innuendo there was
all it was all types of I mean it was
very joke heavy and it was very there
was a lot of winking at the at the older
audience you felt I was just old enough
yeah to know that was out like you were
what well I'm sure there was other
things but you know obviously the
Simpsons which did not make my list was
happening around the same time but
something about the the darkness and the
the weirdness that was the Animaniacs
worldview and the way that they saw
things and the way that they pointed out
things in the way that they talked about
things it was a little bit of that old
school Warner Brothers any you know
crazy physical thing but then it brought
this
lair of smart dark humor was subversive
and it was hitting exactly the right
time in 93 to 98 so I was watching it
you know from basically in high school
like you said and I and at that time
because by the time we're in high school
like schedules a little bit crazy it
would come on after school and so it was
one of those things that I didn't always
see but I never didn't stop and watch it
if it was on and yeah I did again I to
me it made a list because of how it was
revolutionary I think most of the things
in the list for me were revolutionary in
their own right yeah and that's what
made me them revolutionary in my own
life I think it would be higher on my
list if I would have moved on to
watching other animated comedies which
now is this on genre I mean you talked
about you got the whole Adult Swim of it
all and you know I mean yeah the the The
Simpsons obviously didn't make my list
because I I'm still embarrassed to say
I've never watched a complete episode of
The Simpsons it was one of those things
that I I think I was at a young age I
was told you're not supposed we watch we
weren't allowed to watch it weren't
allowed to watch happening when I was
earlier early years and then I I just
wasn't a subversive kid so whenever I
was told not to do something then I just
think I said oh I guess that means all
the way into forever when this show is
like the most amazing show in the
history of television not just animation
the longest-running I don't know what
the record is but it did and I've seen
this emphasis the reason it didn't make
my list is because I it it didn't have
influenced me it wasn't as impactful and
I appreciate the show I think the show
is funny I think that Family Guy is
significantly funnier personally Family
Guy did also did not make my list either
though because they just didn't you know
they got crowded out by the things that
were more influential and more impactful
I'm gonna go
with your 9 number 8 flight of the
conchords season 1 aired in 2007 and I
felt like I had to put it on the list
because from a professional standpoint
it's still something that whenever we
talk about scripted projects we we can't
not mention it yeah I mean even whenever
we talk about our music and we've talked
about this in the past about how I you
know I even have this chip on my
shoulder against those guys because I
think they're so talented and the show
was so great but it's it's it still has
ripple effects through how we do things
because we have to run interference with
how much do we want to be compared with
anything we're developing versus
contrasted with it well and thankfully
they only did it for two seasons yeah I
mean over a decade I'll say that like I
think one of the one of the best things
that ever happened to us is the fact
that Flight of the Conchords decided to
do things on their own
you know because I just think and then
they are playing again I think the
Bret's arm ever he'll I don't know what
the latest of that was but I think they
are playing yeah together again
but we've been huge fans for a long time
it didn't make my list honestly just
because I kind of didn't think about it
when I was from a professional
standpoint I felt like it had it had to
make had to make my list yeah
well not just a good I mean it's great I
mean the tone of it well the fact that
it and I'll say specifically the fact
that it was on HBO but it was such a
specific quirky tone that instead of
going over an edge or saying okay the
pilot episodes got to have nudity in it
I don't care what it is because it's not
HBO you know was they were playing by
their own sets of rules on their edge in
a different place right they found their
edge in the fact that they were weird
and that's very inspirational to um and
obviously the fact that they
incorporated music I mean for four years
when we talked about what our scripted
idea would be you know our first
scripted idea which ended up being
buddy system obviously we we had to
weigh it against the fact that we knew
we were gonna do music videos but like
how could we do this without being
compared to Flight of the Conchords it
turns out the way you do it is just do
it and have nobody will see this show
that you make that's the greatest way to
not be compared to the flight of the
conchords that's a different chip on
earth bring too many into this what's
your next one number seven the office
okay my number seven is the office never
line oh really yes Wow okay the office
ran from 2005 to 2013 yeah and for me
this was what the office represents for
me is sort of my homecoming to half-hour
comedy right yep so there was this
period of time college college where
your schedule is just college is about
movies at least it was yet for us for us
mm-hmm that was that was our drinker of
movies being able to watch whatever you
wanted to there's nobody there to tell
you you can't rent that that you're not
old enough to see that and you just
watch all these movies talking about
porn no I'm not talking about porn
specifically that's a different story we
could do another podcast on that that
was what the what it sounded like you
were telling us what the computer lab in
the library was for but I specifically
the college was about movies and so then
in of course it was it was the south and
we got married right out of school and
got married in 2000 you got me in 2001
and then art it watch the survivor you
know I'm saying yeah and by that point
Seinfeld was was off as you could like
watch reruns or whatever right but you
kind of sitting around waiting for
something good and I just remember all
of a sudden and again I know the the the
brutish offices but oh gosh don't shut
that shut up about that we know it came
from England we know they're funnier
we know they start everything and we
just bite it we've been through that but
but it is different we make it different
yeah
we make it different and we make it for
longer as well and we run it into the
ground so we both started with season
one of the office and I just watched it
for a few years but then kind of fizzled
out I think it was the advent of
children into my life well no Lily was
born 2003 she was born the year that
this started no no together - yeah a lot
was one when I started watching it I
don't know why I don't know why I
fizzled out from watching it but I will
say that when we were hanging out with
Britain when he was on lockdown because
he was on the voice he was just binge
watching the office so he talked to my
kids about it a lot and then Lily
started watching the office and Lincoln
got into it and now
Lando's gotten into it and we all have
started watching the office and I'm
watching I'm I got in at the in their
stream right so now I'm watching the
we're watching the the final Steve
Carell season oh wow
and I've actually you know the office
was my favorite show but again I didn't
get to this point for some life reason
I'm watching it for the first time and
let me tell you it I mean it at least
that season I don't know if it if it hit
a law before it or after he left it hits
a law laughter that they take some time
to find some footing it is had you seen
it because I will say yes masterful
writing like the way that these
characters that you're attached to the
way that they use them and it's just
everything about the way they construct
episodes to give a growing sense of he's
leaving but also a sense of closure
that's not the finale of the season it
happens yeah kind of in the middle of
the season and then what they did after
we with the people with the people that
they bring in and the way that they made
a transition I thought was as brilliant
as you could you could hope for well to
me the reason that the office is was so
revolutionary and so influential for for
me personally again it was it was
innovative right
that we take it for granted but at least
it was for me it was the first thing
that popularized this whole breaking the
fourth wall as part of the show right
and which is a credit I guess to the
Ricky Gervais is right and I'm yeah
you've merchants or whatever his name is
but I'm saying I but I'm saying when it
got to me it was it was the American
version and it was just so like it was
so specifically funny
and like it it was on network but it
wasn't trying to be a show for your
parents it wasn't it wasn't like we got
to do this and we got to take this out
and that's a little too weird so let's
not go there
laugh tracks and none of that yeah right
again first one first real half-hour
that I cared about that it was a single
camp was a single camp so it was
revolutionary and of course then you got
Parks and Rec which was you didn't make
my list because I just feel like it was
it was just like the office I may
actually like it more as a show
ultimately but the office was so
influential and those shows have its the
office especially has had this
incredible resurgence like I was looking
it like the Netflix stats you know me
and the next Netflix stats I'm always in
there you know those are public they
recently published what is the most
streamed that what is most streamed on
platform I don't remember
office may have been number one I can't
remember but it was very high up on the
list of just the number of hours of the
shows that have been streamed in the
office parks and recs really high
because all these our kids are now again
my kids watch the office and there's all
these memes related to the office and
there's a there's this thing that struck
me was like everybody is stupid yeah
like I had forgotten and I felt like I
was I didn't have an appetite for the
whole sitcom like this suspension of
disbelief in order to like no one ever
talks like this no one is this extreme
there's got to be something to ground
this
there's none of that and it's but it's
so masterful that you get over it but I
actually thought I actually thought that
I couldn't get it in to the office or
the good place or any sitka Network
sitcoms anymore even the best ones and I
think they're both amongst it because I
just thought I was more of a I don't
really watch comedies like I watch like
ever since Breaking Bad I'm just like
into gritty if you're gonna you can have
humor in something but like I just don't
have an appetite for comedy anymore and
I thought I'd lost it and I've regained
it you very cool congratulations thanks
to the office and by the way I'm crying
especially at this pocket of this season
I'm crying just as much as I'm laughing
oh yeah it's so they're so good at it
yeah but it's such a it's such a suspend
your disbelief world right I mean the
whole whole sitcom thing like the way
that yeah we're we're gonna have to get
moving fast here what are some are
really special just keep going
number six for me alias all right we're
overlapping again alias I'm putting up
at my number 300 I think is it
represents a new genre of watching I
think we'll say the same thing so go for
it
well yeah well no you go cuz just near
number three it's a ran from 2004 to
only 2005 do I get that right probably
not but no 2001 to 2006 okay I don't
know why I wrote that well I know what
if you watch nine doesn't that's that's
right I watched it he that's that's why
it's on my list but it's on my list
higher because it was the first thing I
ever watched not streaming but on
mail-order DVD first television show
that you you benched that I binge
watched die and that's why it's all me
it was great every episode was it was
kind of self-contained but then not
really because it would have a
cliffhanger at the end you have to watch
the next one and then lo and behold
because I'm a few seasons behind and I
have Blockbuster Video by mail not
Netflix
I can watch I can have two disks mailed
to me I can take one in a blockbuster
hand it in and get the next alias there
while the other ones coming in the mail
I had a whole system yeah couldn't do
that with Netflix at the time because I
do think that it's important to you know
my wife has because it was very
significant part of our marriage of like
yeah now we sit down and we watch a
television show every single night until
we've gone through the entire season
yep binging that never never now that
was a novel concept that just a few of
our friends were starting to do like the
first season we watched the physical
DVDs that somebody had bought and then
given to us yep and then we transitioned
into the blockbuster mail order thing
and I think the I don't think the show
she wants to go back and watch it like
Jesse's like we should watch it again
with the kids and I'm like all right we
can try that we did that with lost em
which almost made my list but didn't and
I think lost did hold up I don't think
the alias is gonna hold up I don't think
that it was masterful television JJ
Abrams is making a new show with Sydney
Bristow Oh Jennifer Garner I just think
that it was just watch that one it was
again innovative ahead of his time and
it changed now we watch hit it hit us at
the exact right time and of course it's
the only way that you watch television
now I mean obviously some people write
if there's a show that's released on a
weekly basis we'll watch it but I kind
of tracked I would we went when we were
out of that we watched Friday Night
Lights we binge doll of that oh gosh we
watched house which is a great show
we watched West Wing we watched 24 which
key for Sullivan hasn't even watched and
completed episode of 24 gotcha
is that a fun fact fun fact Prison Break
and lost like all of a sudden you get
into this binge thing where it's like
well I don't need I don't need
appointments oh that's why I put it
pretty high on my list because it just
changed habits yep what's your next one
number five is northern exposure
northern exposure northern exposure is
my number four oh well I keep
eating you it's like at some point you
must have things high on your list and I
don't have it all that is happening at
the end of your list Northern Exposure
ran from 1990 to 1995 it's funny that a
lot of the things that we really liked
her in this this early 90s to mid 90s it
I love a good world I mean Joel
Fleischman this Jewish doctor is shipped
off to Alaska to like work in this
village and he's like a fish out of
water and he wears a puffy vest and
meets Maggie who has a short hair but
and then there was the old guy who was
Maurice not Maurice was the ex astronaut
Oh
but his Harlan or something like yeah
his archrival who then they became
friends but because they were both
doting over the same girl who was like
18 and then they got married yeah
everything was weird and Ellie you just
felt really weird about watching it but
like it was so good and and then there
was the DJ it was now I'm sure that some
of these tropes they were pulling on
previous television but you had the
really smooth talking not who the smooth
talking he was just like had this silky
smooth voice he was super nice the DJ
who would kind of like help you
understand the world and the way that he
talked and it you had this feeling what
living there it was not the first
because the the show that I'll talk
about that's higher up on my list is the
first show that made me cry at a
television show okay but I cried at this
television show and it was also for me
one of the first shows that I watched
alone I watched it alone so I was making
that transition into a place where okay
my parents have a TV downstairs in their
bedroom by this point you know yeah in
high school there's a television in the
living room and then there's a
television in what we call the extra
room which was that little room upstairs
and this is when I would go into the
extra room and
we watched Northern Exposure now we just
kind of sit there and just be so
immersed you know there was just there
was nothing between me and the world I
was in there my mind my heart were
completely committed to this character
and in this world it was and then I
would justify myself laughing and crying
at the same time it was and it was
comedy written into character quirks not
written into jokes you know it was a
drama
there's a dramedy but it wasn't it
wasn't joke oriented and I actually
think that's something that it is a big
influence on us in terms of like you
want to build a funny world you want to
build a quirky you want to build
weirdness in two characters and setting
and and that can carry a lot of the
comedy and so it's not about a barrage
of jokes it's about relationships and
moving and I do mean a viewer and I
don't think that you know I don't think
we've made anything like that yeah but I
think that is our aspiration it's
influenced us and we want to make
something like that but I think that you
know the main expression of scripted
that we've gotten buddy system is very
very joke heavy and is super surreal
it's weird but it's also like absurdist
and we love that and we want to make
that kind of thing and want to make more
of it but yeah I think that what we
connect with the most is that thing that
is that mix of it's it's that dramedy
that's what we enjoy the most it's also
kind of intimidating to get that right
it's easier to do just crazy joke heavy
comedy you know cuz you know just move
on to the next joke you're not
connecting with this character maybe
you're laughing at him
yeah all right give me your next one
because I only have two left on my
number two what's your number five oh I
number five is fresh prints and you just
okay my number four is northern exposure
my number three is alias my number four
is dukes of hazzard we've already talked
about that which moves meet at number
three which is SNL SNL is your number
three okay SNL is my number two
okay so I think my list is just your
list notched up a couple okay now of
course SNL is running since the 70s
forever is still going yeah oh it's
still going it's yeah it's still
annoying I didn't know I watched the
Matt Damon Christmas episode on my phone
in bed I was like man this is the first
time I watched SNL in years I like watch
one clip and then I end up watching
everything yeah
just laughing out loud I was like I'm
really glad that this is really funny
well and it may it may strike you I
don't know depending how old you are if
you're our age just this probably makes
a lot of sense if you're younger this
may be what this may be a little bit of
a head-scratcher but I think that Lorne
Michaels said it best when he said that
everyone's favorite era of SNL is when
they were in high school and that meant
potentially middle school yeah and then
I think for us it was started in middle
to start it absolutely started in middle
school and that I mean yeah that's my
favorite season I think there was it's
it was actually in the midst of a big
transition period because I kind of
looked into this a little bit because I
I remembered I remembered Chris Rock and
then his last season was I remember nor
McDonald hosting Weekend Update and that
was the first season that Chris Rock was
gone gnorm was there the year before but
you know and then Chris Farley coming in
Will Ferrell came in but it was when why
am i why am i losing the name the
Canadian dude from Wayne's for house
what's his name Mike Meyers yeah Mike
Meyers he was leaving but it a lot of
people say it wasn't a strong point but
for us it was all we had
yeah and if you could you'd stay up as
late as you could and then we'd have to
get up and go to church the next morning
we would like skip out on Sunday school
stand in the hallway and just talk about
the sketches yeah
you remember that oh yeah just obsess
over and then beat him personally well
and we talked about this in the earlier
that I don't remember how long the deep
thoughts by Jack Handey ran
that's right but that was a big thing
for us yeah we actually just insert that
it was inserted in something that we're
working on right now that's right soon
but put a reference in there and it's
also in the in the book of mythicality
yeah you see that in the inserts to our
church bulletin we would write our
versions that deep thoughts by Jackie
that weren't actually funny it was our
it was some of our first comedy writing
and then we met we met who do we meet
that had an important Barry directed
season one a buddy system and he he he
worked on deep thoughts he worked all
you gotta say co-created but I don't
know if that's true I think he worked
with I think he worked with Jack maybe
directed those spots that's right
because Jack Handey was a real person a
writer on SNL and Jack Handey I looked
him up when I was thinking about this
continues to write he had a number of
deep thoughts books the first one
published in 91 or 92 which is why it's
yeah referenced and he continued like
he's like self-publishing he kept doing
it and he's still a humorous that does
these absurd things but anyway also Adam
Sandler songs I mean you start to think
about it really plants a seed I believe
in our minds that like we can write
funny songs well it was our own deed it
was really our only exposure to sketch
comedy absolutely we didn't watch
stand-up well I would watch stand-up on
Showtime of the Apollo
I would or I would watch like a Sinbad
special yeah and I just thought that
Sinbad's comedy specials were the most a
credible thing I'd ever seen
but we didn't a very unapproachable we
weren't really students a comedy in that
we didn't have any anybody was stand-up
wasn't a thing we weren't listening to
like you know old tapes of George Carlin
or whatever a lot of people coming up a
comedy we're getting that but we just
came from a different place and so we
had NBC on Saturday night and you could
stay up yeah there was like this reward
of like oh you guys if you if you can
sneak and stay up late enough and stay
awake what if you can stay up after us
and
you can watch party in progress oh
goodness that's right remember that oh
yeah it was just it was still a thing no
party in progress it was a half hour
show no all it was was a bunch of girls
in bikinis at parties at parties and
they would just film all of I think they
just went to Daytona Beach you're like 2
weeks and my sixth mind it was the best
thing that anyone have could have caught
on film
I mean it was revolutionary and I was
just hoping that no one would walk in it
was just people filming bikini contests
and oh at Daytona Beach and just turning
it into a show for the court for us for
people in colder rod it was made just
for me I thought it was only broadcast
in my television I think I've told the
story before but I gotta mention it
again like the Nielsen ratings people
sent worksheets to our house for
somebody my mom agreed to participate in
the Nielsen ratings thing where you
would write down what shows you watched
every night you took a log and then you
would mail in and you were literally an
eel son I hate witches which made a very
very appropriate conflict of interest
perhaps so we'd handwrite the stuff we'd
watch we watch Entertainment Tonight
every night and then we'd watch I don't
know all the other stuff we watch but
then I remember my mom like set it up to
mail it and I snuck opened it and added
party and progress haha because I wanted
him bold I had to do it drop that party
in progress I had to do my part to like
keep party in progress in progress but I
didn't want my mom to know it party in
progress is my number one others cry
just go ahead and cut to the chase I got
a Google that just to see if it's like
it's just bikini contest that is my
number - I feel like it permeated our
comedic Sensibility to the point that it
earned the next top spot I'm just
uh yeah and this was not easy this
wasn't easy but I accept your apology
what is what is your neck my number two
is the Wonder Years not even on your
list but nope never watched it but I
knew it would be on your list okay so
this ran from 1988 to 1993 starred Fred
Savage and the narrator was Daniel Stern
who played who was yeah every single
level Ginga from home alone yes does all
the the narration as the adult version
of Kevin Kevin Arnold looking back on
his life growing up in the 60s and 70s
and it captured me so all those things I
said about Northern Exposure are twice
as true so this is I mean I'm talking
and again I was the first this was the
first show that I watched by myself okay
and because my parents my parents didn't
care about this show my brother was into
other things and so it just hit me at
this time you know I'm watching it so
Kevin is playing like a twelve-year-old
right and I'm starting to watch this
thing in 1988 when I'm 11 yeah so he's
got this relationship with Winnie he's
gay I did I remember Winnie he's got
who's really she was really great at
math she's super smart and then he's got
his bang he's got his best friend Paul
and he's got his older brother who was a
bully to him so many things about his
life were exact parallels to what I was
going through I had an older brother who
would hold me down and dangle spit over
my face just like his older brother
Wayne was his name and but you had a
friend that was me ice and you were you
were just like Paul you didn't have
glasses as hot where Paul was I can nerd
what do you mean that thought you were
but uh what about a winning he didn't
have who was your winning well you
always have a winning you always have
the girl line you have the girl that
you're fixed for me
had a girl that I was fixated on it just
rotated and but the end was a failure it
was no I nominated him in that it was
just job it was like the feels wrong
there was comedy he was funny it was
funny in exactly the same way that
Northern Exposure was oh really maybe
not as quirky wasn't as northern
Northern Exposure
but no it was funny what I have a
feeling it holds up I don't know I
haven't ever gone back and watched it
would love to watch it with the kids
because she was already cry every
episode right uh well so what I remember
is I remember being in in the extra room
and again just like weeping like I was
so invested and like crying to the point
there like I really hope that my mom
doesn't need anything from me right now
because I am so invested in wonders and
for the same feeling you felt about Part
II in progress but for different reasons
exactly and I don't know it was just it
was so well done and I felt like I was
interestingly I felt like I was getting
this insight into I wasn't exactly
getting insight into my parents
perspective because they were the
generational gap so I was the age of the
people playing the kids but it was from
a time that was a little bit after like
my parents were that age hmm I don't
know how that would have worked out
mathematically that would have been
perfect but I don't know I just felt
like you got this every character was so
well developed and you remove it later
do you remember a moment like like what
was the defining moment do you remember
the finale what no I'm my brain doesn't
work like that
I don't I have a horrible memory when it
comes to the specifics I just remember
the vibe in the general feel but I just
thought about the winning the way that
he thought about girls and his
friendships it was just so relatable cuz
you know me like I at that age at age 11
or 12 I was already completely obsessed
with girls like that wasn't I was
late bloomer and so it I was I already
had the it was fixated on different
girls and imagine what a relationship oh
she was just my girlfriend then
everything would be great and if she was
my girlfriend he would be the only thing
that I cared about and I felt like he
kind of embodied that in a way just the
way that he was dealing with everything
it was the most relatable thing and it
was just incredibly well done it's very
dramatic I I just I just didn't have an
appetite for that drama at that point
but you like Northern Exposure but you
like Northern Exposure later because
this can happen yeah earlier because you
would have been you know ten years old
or so when it started well it seems that
we are each to our number one and I
pretty much know at this point that we
agree because we both left off it's just
painfully obvious at this point that we
agree on our number one and isn't that
fabulous yes it is so our number one is
Green Acres I actually watched Green
Acres I didn't i watch reruns of that
seriously our number one is Seinfeld
absolutely so Seinfeld ran from 1989 to
1998 so once it really hit its stride
after a couple of seasons it was in our
high school sweet spot when it was in
its sweet spot and I remember again
appointment viewing I hunkered down in
my bed I'd get my homework done or I'd
say well it's gotta wait and if I would
I would tell mom I'm watching Seinfeld
in my room hold my calls
like I remember Michael Juby called me
to do some homework and I was like it
was like I answered the phone ten
minutes before it came on and I like
talked to him for nine minutes and then
I was like hey dude I know this
conversations not anywhere near over but
I got to go cuz Seinfeld is coming on
like I was not going to miss it yeah it
was so the comedic voice was so specific
and so unique to anything I had been
exposed to
I mean we were I think we were primed
for that Larry David cynicism because
though we didn't watch Letterman I mean
your dad had that dry wit we we
resonated with that I watch that and it
is what the same time I just think that
we were that type of observational dry
sense of humor was something that we
that really resonated with us well yeah
it was the kind of thing where when they
were riffing on something you weren't
just laughing at it you were reveling in
it you know what I'm saying so like you
were so blown away by the choices that
were being made in the way that the
jokes were coming to the way that the
jokes would just happen and then the way
that the whole story would come together
at the end and these ridiculous plot
lines would come together in this
completely stupid way yeah there was it
it was a what they would weave us they
would weave three stories well it was
light it would all pay off in one moment
it was like grabbing something that has
the exact same vibrational energy like
you grab onto something that is
vibrating at the frequency that your
body is vibrating at and it creates this
and I know that sounds crazy and you
listen but it felt you could feel it
yeah it it is it transcended and now let
me just address something now Ethan of
h3h3 did an incredible job of addressing
this when he reacted to the react video
teens react where the teens were
reacting to Seinfeld and basically just
watch that I I just put h3h3 Seinfeld
yeah because their basic premise and
basically I remember everything single
thing that Ethan said but his
perspective is my perspective and that
is the fact that I mean I part of it was
the fact that was something that was
being done on the show modern kids felt
like they made him feel uncomfortable
but they didn't get the joke it seemed
culturally insensitive but they and and
I'm sure it was that certain points but
in lots of times that was the joke
right they were making it was commentary
but a lot of people are like I don't
understand why it's funny you know these
characters seem ridiculous everybody's
super selfish and it's like exactly and
I didn't know I didn't really did that
that like okay this is a I mean they
talked about how it's a show about
nothing because they made a show within
the show they conceptualized the show
within the show right and they tried to
sell it you know which again that's just
great it's just so creative itself well
for Mitchell but I couldn't have said
well Jerry doesn't change like we're
gonna break the rule like that was a
ground rule that I couldn't have
articulated it's like well for
successful writing you the characters
have one arc nobody changed like nobody
changes nobody grows nobodies they're
all bad they're bad people
yeah right and they don't grow they're
all completely so [ __ ] but it free I
mean it and there's there are characters
I mean you look at house like a very
comedic ly self-centered flawed
character but I dropped off maybe he
changes it was like they stuck to their
guns to them yeah well I think they like
got kind of schmaltzy with this Green
Day montage but other than that but I
think that the reason again this is
completely subjective right this is very
subjective we're not talking about what
the greatest television shows are of all
time this is the most influential and I
think that even what you ever you think
is the greatest is is so subjective it's
that thing that I'm talking about some
intersection of our background and our
sensibilities that were some weird
combination of nature and nurture primed
us to be completely ready to accept this
I think part of it had to do and I think
that you articulated the way that we
think about it now or the fact that all
these characters are selfish and they
don't change we wouldn't have been able
to talk say that at the time but one of
the reasons I think that appealed to us
is that we were in this the culture that
we were growing up in it was like we
were good boys and we were being told
how to be good boys and the things that
you should believe in the things that
you should the way you should
behave and I think that all of a sudden
these people from New York who were all
single didn't have kids didn't aspire to
get married or have kids and we're not
playing by any of the rules that all the
adults are in our lives were playing but
it was this opposites attract thing and
like I said it was but we had this
yearning for some some kind of release
and instead of going out and doing
irresponsible things we watched shine
houses we did some irresponsible things
but we we watched Seinfeld
we watched I mean I think SNL served the
same purpose in all always it was like
it's a way to kind of revel in this
thing where you kind of need a break
from the setting that you live in and
I'm not saying that kids growing up in
New York didn't like Seinfeld but for us
everything just lined up and it's the
way that we who's your favorite
character oh that's a that's a really
good question I mean I think it might be
it might be either Jerry or George's dad
who has ben stiller's dad yeah um
Kramer's of a favorite character oh yeah
I love Kramer every time he entered
every everyone would cheer yeah well he
was great cuz he would enter it was like
a throwback like he was like a throwback
to an earlier time it was also the only
character who actually wasn't 100%
selfish he actually was a good friend he
was selfish at the same time but he was
a good friend yeah he was also an ass
man yeah so the that license plate jon
voight scar right yes so and so this is
something it guys our age people our age
who work in comedy have these you have
this just the way that Larry David
thought kind of constantly running
through your your mind and you're trying
to make sure that you're not just
writing a scene or a joke that is unless
that's just Seinfeld or that's what is
now Curb Your Enthusiasm which is a sort
of a remix it's so influential that you
just have to make sure that you're not
going there all the time
and another reason you don't want to go
there all the time is because you know
20-year old people don't care about it
don't think it's funny it's like they
don't find it funny anymore because I
was trying to things change you're not
long you figure out you're different if
my kids would be into it like hey you
like Parks and Rec you like the office I
started researching does it hold up they
would not and my people who love it say
it does hold up but I have I'm gonna
test it on my kids I was talking to him
about it last night
you know Britain's a big influence I'm
gonna use it we'll hold up because Eddie
loved it so I bet you I can get my kids
to love it here's the one thing that
doesn't hold up there's a lot of phone
humor and it's all written before the
advent of cell phones and Google like
specifically not I'm not even singing
the Internet but like a lot of phone
humor and why not give me an example
answering machine humor that's just what
I read I don't remember an example but
and then I was reading an article that
said if you're gonna introduce it to
somebody you should watch it in Reverse
like start with season 19 or whatever it
was watch that for words but then watch
18 17 16 I don't know how many seasons I
thought that may season because it was
there just as many seasons that there
are years right typically that's how
that's done anyway that brings us to our
number one I do want to I don't think
it's on a streaming service
interestingly and can't watch I felt and
I don't think you can I think you got a
you got to own it nine seasons you have
to get the nine seasons on DVD it's at
least what I've been told we'll have to
look into that but all right so we've
we've completed our list and you hung
with us this is a longer ear biscuit but
wait thanks for hanging with us and let
us know what you think about this format
is something that we might do again
y'okay you can't watch the all Seinfeld
on Hulu ticket just let us know
Thank You Jacob let us know if you want
you know what you thought about sort of
this ranking reminiscing kind of thing
because obviously we can do this with
things other than television shows I
enjoy talking about it
yeah so use hashtag ear biscuits let us
know what you thought and will speak at
you again next week
mm-hmm can i rattle off my honourable
mention since we were we have time to
fill sure Reading Rainbow Inspector
Gadget The Jetsons 18 small wonder
watch that after-school small wonder the
the robot in 2007 she was a nurse in
Boulder Community Hospital in Boulder
Colorado I tried to find out what she's
up to now Vicki had a crush on Vicki
punky brewster also had a crush on her
The Ellen DeGeneres Show I almost made
my list hmm because it's like it was the
first lesbian that came into my home
every single day right course now I got
all the types of lesbians coming into my
home that's right I love it
yep but I mean she was the first one I
didn't why didn't well I didn't watch it
well now even now yes I mean not the
sitcom the show that still on now oh
yeah I thought you talked about this
[ __ ] the sitcom it's been on a long time
though Letterman The Cosby Show the why
are Breaking Bad and Mad Men some of my
favorite television shows that's when
you get into the best television shows
of all time I'd definitely be breaking
those out and The Price is Right
the only thing on my honorable mention
that you didn't cover on your list or
their with Simon and Simon good theme
song and we also talked about perfect
strangers you mentioned it that almost
made my list as well but which
interestingly both our shows are about
two guys Simon and Simon private
investigators yeah you know the
rough-and-tumble like ex ex vet and then
like the pretty boy and then Larry and
Balki of the perfect strangers
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]